c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soit il est bienvenu sur france 24 est
la une ce soir le forum mondial de l'eau
qui ouvre ses portes à dakar au sénégal
c'est la première fois que cet important
rendez vous consacré à l'or bleu se
tient en afrique subsaharienne on ira
justement sénégal voir comment certains
quartiers de la capitale souffre de
pénurie
l'opération conjointe entre l'armée
ougandaise et l'armée congolaise dans
l'est de la république démocratique du
congo objectif traquer les abf cette
ministre ougandaise responsables de
massacres en rdc et d'attentât à kampala
reportage exclusif avec l'armée
ougandaise dans ce journal
l'interdiction des taxis motos taxis
vélos des toc toc à bujumbura au burundi
la mesure est entrée en vigueur
aujourd'hui elle a été plutôt respectée
même si elle est loin de faire
l'unanimité chez les usagers
le forum mondial de l'eau ouvre ses
portes pour une semaine à dakar un
rendez vous important qui n'a lieu que
tous les trois ans
c'est la première fois qu'il se tient en
afrique subsaharienne selon les nations
unies seul un africain sur quatre accès
à l'eau potable et les centres urbains
ne sont pas épargnés exemple à dakar
malgré les efforts pour satisfaire la
forte demande des quatre millions
d'habitants de la capitale sénégalaise
beaucoup de dakarois penta y accéder
reportage de nos correspondants sarah
sakho et élima n'dao
le robinet d'ousmane est désespérément
sec ce père de famille habite à ouakam
un quartier de dakar touchés par des
coupures d'eau et des familles ont
éliminé matin il devrait donc il des
femmes doit toko toute une nuit l'union
il y aura moins donc on vraiment c'est
oublier donc aux brimades les déboulés
de gauche
d'après vraiment se mettre
d'accord connaît une urbanisation
galopante avec une croissance
démographique annuelle de 3% sa demande
d'eau potable n'est pas une guerre mois
satisfaites
les l'art du pneu arménie cet activiste
est à la tête d'une plateforme digitale
de défense des consommateurs il revoit
régulièrement des plaintes de dakarois
privé du liquide précieux une capitale
comme dakar on ne peut pas comprendre
moi personnellement je ne peux pas
comprendre qu'en 2022 qu'on puisse être
là à parler des problèmes d'eau on a
plusieurs moyens c'est à des
manifestations pétitions rencontre le
directeur on va essayer on va pas on va
vraiment essayer tous les moins complet
avec tous les
problèmes la société nationale des eaux
du sénégal exploite principalement le
lac de guerre située à 300 km de la
capitale pour soulager les populations
d'ici 2025 la société mis sur une
exploitation de loups de mer
ça va permettre de
diversifier les sources de production de
l'eau la distribution de l'eau et donc
sera beaucoup plus améliorer la
disponibilité sera également aussi
l'état compte également sur une nouvelle
usine de traitement d'eau potable
constructs dernièrement elle apportera
dans les prochains mois cinq mille
mètres cubes d'eau supplémentaires par
jour dans les réseaux dakarois
la mort en détention de l'ancien premier
ministre malien soumeylou boubèye maïga
dans une clinique de bamako il avait été
détenu à la maison d'arrêt de bamako
pendant quatre mois il avait été
transféré en décembre dans la clinique
de bamako où il est décédé il avait été
incarcéré après son inculpation pour
faux usage de faux et favoritisme
et puis toujours au mali le médiateur de
la cedeao goodluck johnatan a quitté à
bamako dimanche après deux jours de
visite sans accord avec l'agente
malienne sur une date pour
l'organisation d'élections la date de
des scrutins présidentielle et
législatives initialement prévues fin
février n'a pas été respecté
médecins sans frontières va arrêter ses
activités dans deux sites de la province
de l'ituri zee nisy pardon et boum boum
dans le nord-est de la république
démocratique du congo lorenjy pointe du
doigt l'insécurité grandissante et les
attaques répétées contre les populations
et contre ses structures et son
personnel le 28 octobre dernier deux de
ses employés ont été grièvement blessés
par balles lors d'une boue embuscade
plus de 400 mille civils sont concernés
par le retrait de msf écoutez
nous sommes certes là pour aller sauver
des vies
nous sommes nous évoluons dans des zones
risquées mais ne pouvait pas assumer
d'exposer nos collègues à des risques
importants ce moment c'est aussi
l'occasion de réitérer auprès des
différentes parties au conflit aux
autorités mais également à toutes les
personnes influentes
la nécessité du respect du droit
humanitaire
la nécessité du respect des populations
civiles nous nous rendons bien compte
que suite à cette augmentation des cas
de violations du droit international
humanitaire il ya de plus en plus les
acteurs qui quitte ses en intervention
et msf
reste des plus en plus seul face à des
besoins qui augmentent donc c'est
vraiment une situation qui est réel et
aujourd'hui c'est pour nous l'occasion
le pouvoir tirer la sonnette d'alarmé et
surtout exprimer notre mécontentement
parce que pour nous c'est inacceptable
donc on devrait pas se permettre
d'attaquer des ambulances avec les
patients à bord du personnel médical
pour rappel les massacres sont quasi
quotidiens dans cette province et dans
la province voisine du nord-kivu ce
week-end encore quatorze personnes
déplacées ont été tués dans le
territoire de dungu
les codeco sont pointés du doigt un
groupe armé qui prétend défendre les
intérêts de la communauté landou
dans l'est de la république de la
république du congo il y à un autre
groupe réputé pour commettre des
massacres il s'agit des adf milice
islamiste originaire de l'ouganda voisin
une milice traquer grâce à une opération
conjointe entre l'armée ougandaise et
l'armée congolaise pour la première fois
une télévision internationale a été
autorisé à accompagner les troupes
rwandaises en territoire congolais
reportage de notre envoyé spécial
bastien renouveler
ces véhicules ougandais s'apprête à
pénétrer en république démocratique du
congo le convoi va ré approvisionner les
troupes qui traque les adf un groupe
armé actif dans les provinces du nord
kivu et de l'ituri mais ça mérite à la
cour c'est un convoi militaire
matériel nous apportons du matériel des
vivres nous pas avancer dans les
villages de boga et kahina ma
il y à des véhicules blindés parce qu'on
ne sait jamais ce qui peut se passer
aussi les rebelles adf que nous traquons
tous qu'il est arrivé
pour rejoindre leur base de kahina ma
ils doivent franchir la rivière qui
marque la frontière et ont emprunté ce
chemin aménagé par l'armée sur 80 km on
y croise des patrouilles ougandaise
censé garantir la sécurité des villages
mais peau de soldats congolais ces
maisons ont été désertés après des
massacres commis par les miliciens nous
nous arrêtons à cha by la chefferie est
de nouveau fonctionnel depuis une
semaine sont responsables parlent en
présence des militaires donc oui on
amène les gens commencent à revenir ici
le gouvernement a demandé de reprendre
mon poste maintenant que l'armée
ougandaise en coordination avec l'armée
congolaise a su notre sécurité en
donnant à what was
quelques kilomètres plus loin le camp
avancé de l'armée ougandaise le général
responsable de l'opération y supervise
les offensives et objective l'objectif
de cette opération c'est de détruire les
adf réduire à néant leur capacité à
faire la guerre
stratégiquement nous voulons créer un
environnement pacifique et ainsi nous
pourrons avoir des échanges commerciaux
fluide contre nos deux pays tous
les attaques repousse selon lui les
miliciens loin de la frontière il compte
alors sur les forces congolaises
stationné au nord et à l'ouest des deux
provinces pour les stopper
la tra glisse deux à trois mille
personnes familles des combattants
inclus
dans las de l'actualité en bref et en
images cette nouvelle attaque au burkina
faso très soldats ont été tués dans une
embuscade dans l'est du pays selon un
communiqué des forces armées les
militaires sont tombés dans cette
embuscade alors qu'ils menaient une
opération de sécurisation
l'ouverture ce lundi du dialogue
républicain centrafricain dialogue
promis de longue date par le président
touadéra il elle va pourtant se faire
sans les principaux partis d'opposition
la quasi totalité d'entre eux comptent
annoncé qu'ils boycottaient la rencontre
parce que leurs exigences ne sont pas
satisfaites il avait pourtant participé
aux préparatifs
la collision de deux trains en tunisie
le bilan fait état de près de 100
blessés l'accident est survenu dans le
sud de tunis la capitale l'un des trains
transportaient des passagers le second
est évident les causes de l'accident ne
sont pas encore connus
direction le burundi où l'interdiction
des taxis motos taxis vélos et des
touches boucle dans la plus grande
partie de la capitale économique
bujumbura est entré en vigueur
aujourd'hui une mesure plutôt respectée
même si elle est loin de satisfaire les
usagers laurent berthet cher
son toughbook ni moto taxi c'est
burundaise se pressent pour monter dans
l'un des rares bus desservant la
capitale économique
depuis lundi matin les deux roues ne
peuvent plus circuler dans le centre
ville de bujumbura
une mesure particulièrement décriée par
les chauffeurs contraint de changer
d'activité pour survivre
cette nouvelle nous a vraiment
bouleversés nous qui conduisons ce
véhicule
ils nous permettent de nourrir nos
familles
on février le ministre de l'intérieur
burundais accusait les deux roues d'être
responsables de la majorité des
accidents de la route et annonçaient
leur interdiction dans la plupart des
quartiers de bujumbura
entrée en vigueur lundi la nouvelle loi
interdit également usage privé de vélos
et de scooters un casse tête logistique
pour nombre de burundais qui dépendent
de ces moyens de transport alternatifs
pour se déplacer
je ne vois pas vraiment ce que je
pourrais demander au parce que je ne
peux rien changer cette décision a été
soutenu par pas mal de monde beaucoup de
gens souffrent mais on ne peut rien
faire au total environ 20 mille
véhicules sont concernés par
l'interdiction
impactant le quotidien de plus de 600
milles burundi
pour finir je vous emmène sur l'île
maurice vous allez voir que le passage
de deux cyclones en février dernier a
causé beaucoup de dégâts pas tant de
dégâts matériels s'est surtout
l'agriculture qui a été durement touché
de nombreuses récoltes ont été détruites
reportage de notre correspondant
abdallah et rallye
maurice a déclenché l alerte cyclonique
maximale à deux reprises en l'espace de
vingt jours le mois dernier
du jamais vu dans l'histoire les
tempêtes bâtir aie aie aie mme natty
n'ont pas causé de dégâts majeurs aux
infrastructures mais ont été
dévastatrices pour la culture vivrière
madan a perdu 80% de sa production dans
son exploitation familiale à hermitage
ça va pas grossir
en espace de deux semaines une perte de
80% sur une production qui devrait
s'étaler pour une récolte de deux mois
sur trois mois nous faisons plusieurs
types de récolte à la fois mais
recommencer à zéro pratiquement ce jeune
agriculteur s'est lancé dans la culture
de tomates il a démarré sa première
production en octobre et s'apprêter à
récolter les fruits de ses premiers
efforts j'ai récolté seulement dix jours
et puis avait une cyclo negra maurice
bartz hirai c'est pendant les 11ème jour
vous voyez là c est toujours endommagé
j' avais ses 350 mais europe est dedans
et j'ai récolté sa mort jean mérault
paix depuis 2007 maurice n'avait plus
subi une tempête l'agriculture sous
serre qui s'est développée depuis le
dernier cyclone adopter des structures
peu adaptés aux conditions extrêmes mais
ça fait 20 ans qu'on n'a pas de cyclones
des structures ont été construits des
structures qui ne sont pas adaptés pour
les vents aussi important c'est une
structure en carbone abîmé jusqu'à
hauteur de son poisson de ne pas voir
cyclone pendant 20 ans et puis deux d'un
coup c'est un changement majeur dans le
climat que nous avons dans le sérail
tient au marché de va quoi certains
états sont encore vides trois semaines
après pour pallier la pénurie de légumes
locaux maurice importé d'urgence 2000
tonnes de produits vivriers d'afrique du
sud d'inde et d'égypte notamment ils
sont vendus à des prix subventionnés
dans treize le co gérée par les
autorités
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'afrique reste avec nous dans quelques
instants la suite de paris direct avec
audrey racines
[Musique]